espadrille correspondent in tokyo fatty
salami fatty as feared the death toll
has gone up bring us up to speed with
the latest first yes until now we have
the default at 58% and now there are
about 15 people who are still missing
and many people expect that this
Rhinestone that it's the toll will rise
again because now more and more we are
getting the picture of the size of this
devastation that reached many of the
small communities small villages where
many elderly are living and it seems
that those numbers of this and any
people who couldn't evacuate or didn't
find the shelter and the right time is
what is causing the increase the huge
increase actually in the people who've
escaped Fatih what is happening to them
and what sort of assistance have they
been getting well we have the numbers
are showing us that around the thousand
homes are partially or totally destroyed
because of the flooding we have to
understand that the main effect of this
typhoon which one is which is one of the
strongest that hit Japan during the last
50 years wasn't wasn't the huge wind or
the fast wind but rather the huge
rainfalls it reached around 1,000
millimeters in some areas where and this
amount accumulates to about three months
of the rainfall in those areas so many
areas we are not expecting this huge
rainfalls and this is what was the huge
huge disaster that we're seeing now so
many of the people who flooded who fled
their houses they went to the evacuation
centers and now we are getting different
numbers about this about how many people
they evacuated some people with them
around $30,000 say about five thousand
the difference is because that some of
the people are going in and out of their
evacuation centers to go to clean their
houses and then come back
of course now all of the country is like
not in the mood for this
such a disaster Japan is preparing for
celebrations for the installment of the
Emperor exactly a week from now and some
people are saying that this disaster may
affect the size of the ceremonies and
maybe cancel part of the ceremonies that
going to witness within a week thank you
for that fatty salami lie forests in
Tokyo